I'd like to do this nick has battled for
whiterun I'm [ __ ] excited my dick is
quivering I precum dripping from the
size I am ready for this this is it it's
fall and that we are nothing more than
Israel I thought wait when was like way
over here right now
oh we are farmers we are craftsmen we
are sons and daughters of shopkeepers
maid service and soldiers and offers of
Skyrim and we have come this far because
our calls is true mr jaitley fight as
one and because our hearts aflame with
anger we do my country for all the true
nor the skyrim of all their old and
crumbling like the Empire whose legion
like them but we can't fool them and the
Imperials behind them our objective is
the drawbridge if we can find a way to
drop it the city will be ours I gotta
fetch everyone on me let's show these
Imperial self
[Applause]
what's the hoodie or is an American
ah
yo [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] get my tip
why here
that [ __ ] head or bring that down
[Music]
you [ __ ] suck
yeah white rod
there's that [ __ ] all right box huh
Oh
yo
oh yeah you like that you like fire pit
just for suspension around there late
for that don't you think stay back Lord
I'm damned if I let this travel take my
city without raising my own sword enough
that's enough I surrender I surrender me
everyone stands out that's an order you
should be talking to my steward I
surrender give me a few hours to ignore
grey me your family was noticeably
absent from the walls now I know why
wouldn't a dagger in the parish of
advice you seek sis personal the Empire
has no place in Skyrim but not anymore
and you you have no place in Whiterun
anymore a convenient position to hold my
lacks but mark my words old man in the
days to come Ulfric will spread his
rebellion pin and what then we any other
employer as much as we need us we Nords
are the Empire our blood built it our
blood sustained
you of all people should know that if
this was my Empire I'd be able to
worship whoever i damned well pleased
you wish to see an empire with our
palace without it soul we should be
fighting those which elves not quitting
need them there's nothing more than a
prophet of the foul ball yes yes I agree
Skyrim needs a high king who will fight
for her and white run needs a yarrow who
will do the same tell me Kim aro was all
this worth it how many of those corpses
lining our streets where the faces of
men who once called you friends what
about their families you know what a
challenge there is a burning City out
there that needs a government he's right
Galba come let us restore order this
isn't Oh dear me you old fool this isn't
over and you stormcloak I thought better
of you you'll all come to regret this
day get over to ven helm yellow flex
hollow victory okay thank ya